Plants evolved here on Earth, but what if
we could take them with us to the stars?
Hey gang, Trace here for DNews with your Weekly
Space Update.
Last year, NASA announced we'd found water
on Mars, and that got some people thinking...
could future astronauts grow crops in the
Martian soil?
It's taken us thousands of years to hone farming
on Earth; we could plant crops 'til the cows
come home but what's good for the Earth goose
may not be good for the Martian gander.
Soil needs a lot more than water to grow a
plant.
Soil on Earth contains living and dead organisms
including bacteria and plant matter, rocks
and minerals, and nutrients like nitrogen
-- it takes more than 500 years to form an
inch of topsoil on Earth.
As far as we know, Mars doesn't have organisms
living in its soil to aerate and break down
the matter -- so this is a huge challenge.
Not all dirt is created equal, there are 70,000
different types of soil in the United States
alone!
So, to simulate Martian soil we had to gather
information about Mars.
The Mars Science Laboratory, Curiosity has
been doing JUST THAT, when it wasn't joyriding
around Mars and snapping selfies, of course.
Martian soil contains carbon dioxide, oxygen
and sulfur compounds as well as carbonates
-- or things that indicate a presence of water.
NASA gathered soil samples on Mars and then
composed an approximation of Martian soil
using the volcanic soil of Hawaii.
From there, plant ecologist Wieger Wamelink
planted 14 plants and grew them over 50 days.
Obviously, the plants were given carbon dioxide,
oxygen and water, but it's not just the obvious
resources.
The seeds of a plant can sustain growth for
a while, that's what they're for -- to help
the plant gain a foothold.
According to PhysOrg, Wamelink expected the
plants to germinate and then die due to a
lack of nutrients.
The researchers were surprised to find the
plants did quite well, using the phosphorus
and iron oxides to take root.
Unfortunately, the fact the plants grew in
a difficult soil environment is only one small
part of the puzzle.
The lower gravity and temperature of Mars
will make it difficult for water to be pulled
into the soil, and tougher for plants to evaporate
their excess moisture.
Plus, the sun is much farther away, so any
Martian plants will need extra light.
They're thinking LEDs at the moment, but no
one is quite sure.
The moon is much closer, only a few days away.
So, to Newt Gingrich's delight, the moon will
probably be the location of Earth's first
extraterrestrial colony.
Wamelink is also trying to grow crops in the
moon's soil, called regolith.
Because our moon has no atmosphere, the regolith
contains mainly meteorite pummeled rock dust,
micrometeor debris, rocks and volcanic glass...
Not to mention radiation from the unchecked
solar wind.
It would be HUGE if we can manage to get crops
to take root in ANY capacity on another planet.
Not only for food, but for oxygen recycling,
and to give colonists something to DO all
day.
It can get pretty boring to sit around in
a spacecraft all the time.
But that's... another story...
And if this doesn't give you the train conductor
kick in the head excitement about the future,
how about Shots of Awe with Jason Silva?
Watch Jason explore technology, space, human
nature and love.
... Whoa.
What does your gut tell you?
Are EARTH plants going to grow on the moon
or Mars?
Tell us below and subscribe for more DNews!
Thanks for tuning in, you guys are the best.